-Welcome back. We are hanging
out with the talented Gal Gadot.
Now, last time
you were on our show,
you tried a Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup for the first time.
-Right, and it was
a very nice experience.
-I'm happy that that happened.
You also brought me
an Israeli snack.
-Because I love you so much.
-Thank you,
and the love is mutual.
Today I thought we could take
turns trying some more foods
that we haven't had before.
Does that sound good?
-I don't know. Let's see.
[ Laughs ]
-I know. I don't even want to
look at what I'm having.
But alright.
-[ Laughs ]
-I got yours. So you have stuff
that you've never had before.
And this is the first time
you're trying this.
So, this is a holiday classic
that I personally love
that you've never had before.
It's called egg nog. Okay.
-Is it safe to drink?
-Of course it's safe.
-Is it with alcohol?
-Normally, you put rum in it,
but don't have to.
You can have it nonalcoholic.
It's like -- you know, nog was
a thing -- a holiday thing.
It's almost like a --
it's very festive,
a little cinnamon in there.
-Okay.
-Yeah, I think it's --
-But the egg is cooked?
Like, it's okay?
It's been pasteurized, right?
-No, I don't think
the egg is cooked.
There's no -- You won't get
clumps of egg in there.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's just called egg nog.
I honestly don't even know if
what you're drinking has egg.
-Oh, there's no eggs in this?
-It's all chemicals,
chemical eggs.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, great.
-Take a sip.
Let's see what happens.
Egg nog for the first time.
[ Laughs ]
You looked at me like I did
something bad to you.
-No, it's -- it's --
it's just --
I don't want to hurt
the people's feelings.
-Oh, it's not the people.
There is no people
behind egg nog.
-The company.
-Trust me, the world --
There is no company.
-Maybe with rum it's better,
but it's just very, uh...
-Thick?
-Thick, yeah.
-Alright, so you say
it was almost like pudding,
maybe or something
or what is it like?
-It's like pudding, but it's
more liquid than pudding,
but it's still like...
-Okay, alright,
so not your favorite.
Not your favorite.
Alright, great.
Now, you have a food for me.
-Yes, the first one is --
You see, this is how much
I like you.
Because I bring you
sufganiyot for Hanukkah.
-Uh-huh.
-And this is basically dough,
fried dough filled with jelly.
-What is it called again?
-Sufganiyot.
-Soukinnia?
-[ Laughs ]
Bless you. Sufganiyot.
[ Laughter ]
-It comes in threes --
sou fing ya.
-[ Laughs ]
"Sou fing ya!"
-I got one more. I got one more.
Come on.
It's coming. It's coming.
Sou fing ya.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, so I'm just gonna go --
it's like a jelly doughnut?
-Yeah.
It's the best when it's fresh
out of the oil.
But it's delicious, right?
I mean, pure goodness.
-Un-un-unbelievable.
That is delicious.
That's one of the best jelly
doughnuts I've ever had.
I'll have another bite.
I loved it.
-Yeah, go for it.
You see the jelly? Ah!
-Come on.
-Now I'm jealous.
-I have more surprises for you.
-I know, but I'm not looking
forward to them.
-No, no, these are all good.
-[ Laughs ]
-Next up, you've got
a classic American snack.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is Ho-Hos.
-Okay, this is the chocolate,
right?
-Yes.
-I like chocolate.
-Yeah, of course.
So, these are Ho-Hos.
And you've never had
a Ho-Ho before,
so this is very exciting.
-Who came with the name?
-Santa?
-Like, who thought about Ho-Ho
as a great name for a snack?
-Santa Claus.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Okay, ready?
-Here you go, Ho-Ho.
-It's sweet.
-[ Laughs ]
You're a tough critic.
I love it.
You say what you like.
-No, it's good.
It's really sweet,
it's good, it's soft.
-Okay.
-It's soft. It's delicious.
I enjoy it.
-I love this.
-I'm going to have another bite.
-There you go.
Alright. So you like the Ho-Ho.
Here we go. Here we go.
-Right. The Ho-Ho is good.
-Next up here,
this is a treat for me
because I am very excited
about this.
I cannot believe that you've
never had this -- Taco Bell.
-Never. Never had that.
I don't even know
how it's going to look like.
So I have two here.
Which one do you want me to try?
-Try -- Yeah, try that one
in your hand.
Yeah, that one.
-This one?
-Yes.
-It smells good.
It's like a pita bread.
It's like a taco.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Probably --
yeah, hopefully, yeah.
It's a taco, but here we go.
Taco Bell for the first time.
-Mmm!
-Look at those eyes!
They're sparkling!
That was a win!
Oh, I'll take that!
Yes!
-This is the best so far.
-I love that too.
-Flavorful.
-Right?
-It's salty.
-I'm so happy.
-Different textures.
-Oh, I almost want to play
a replay of your face
because it was honestly like,
"This actually is good."
I would never try to trick you,
just so you know.
I'd never do that to you.
-That was really good.
-Oh, I love that you did this.
-I'm going to have another bite.
-Oh, my God, I love this.
Gal, my last one here.
-Oh, this is amazing! I can't
believe I've never tried them.
-I'm a little scared,
I've got to be honest.
What is this?
-I know.
It's gefilte fish. I'm sorry.
Look, did they bring
any horseradish next to it?
-No.
-That's a problem.
I just don't want you to have,
you know, bad impression
on gefilte fish 'cause --
[ Laughs ]
-Honestly, seriously, Gal,
I swear this looks like
floating -- looks like --
honestly, you know, I can't even
want to say what it looks
like -- floating balls.
-Yeah, it looks like it's worse
than the egg nog.
-And it's like
a thick gravy juice.
-It's not gravy. It's jelly.
It's like from the -- [ Laughs ]
-Stop. Sorry I asked.
-It's from the gelatin
from the bone of the fish.
[ Laughs ]
-Dude, this is so --
like, honestly --
I can't even lift this thing.
-And the fish is the fish.
But it's like a cooked fish.
-Oh, God.
I'm sorry. Oh, I can't watch.
Okay.
-Alright, oh, God.
It looks like a meatball.
-I'll have the Taco Bell
while you eat this.
-No, I want you to
have the egg nog!
[ Laughter ]
Alright, it looks
like a meatball.
So it's like a fish meatball.
-Just shove it in already.
Don't think about it too much.
Chew, chew, chew, chew, chew.
Is he okay? Is he okay?
He's not okay.
[ Laughs ]
It's okay.
It's actually growing on you.
-Is it growing on me? Where?
[ Laughter ]
That's not bad.
I like it.
-See? You did that.
And with a good horseradish...
-With horseradish would crush.
-It's so good.
-Hey, not bad.
If they changed the way
it looked and the packaging...
-If they take away
the jelly thingy.
-But I think -- I think I like.
I think gefilte fish.
-Jimmy Fallon
likes gefilte fish.
-For the first time.
-Success!
-I love this.
-I've done my work in the world.
-Gal, you are the best.
I love you.
Thanks for playing this game
with me.
-I love you.
-You're always up for any game
and you always crush.
I love you. I know how much work
went into "Wonder Woman 1984."
It's in select theaters finally
on IMAX December 25th.
It'll also be available same day
on HBO Max.
Thank you so much.